we begin with new comments from
President Biden on the war in Ukraine
and his approach to dealing with
Vladimir Putin following this week's
deadly Russian airstrikes here's what he
told Jake Tapper on CNN
when I'm talking about I'm talking to
Putin
he in fact cannot continue with impunity
to talk about the use of a tactical
nuclear weapon as if that's a rational
thing to do the mistakes get made and
the miscalculation could occur no one
can be sure what would happen and it
could end an Armageddon
this comes after earlier remarks from
the president suggesting we are closer
to an Armageddon now than we have ever
been really than we've been in 60 years
Charlie dagada is in Ukraine for us
where tensions remain high Charlie good
morning
good morning tense is the word that
kremlin's saying that President Biden's
remarks are part of harmful and
provocative Western nuclear rhetoric
while more air raid sirens rang out here
and across the country including the
capital
following days of Russian aerial
bombardment
on a scale unseen since the start of the
war here spreading not just destruction
but Terror across the country Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski implored
the leaders of the G7 for help against
aerial attacks
when Ukraine receives a sufficient
quantity of modern and effective air
defense systems he said the key element
of Russia's Terror rocket strikes will
cease to work
an assault that is also seen the
increasing use of these iranian-made
Shaheed 36 Kamikaze drones shown here on
Iranian State tv the dramatic
retaliatory escalation after the
explosion that struck the Crimean Bridge
coincided with Putin's promotion of a
new Hardline Commander Sergey sorovicin
formerly the commander of Russia's Air
Force known as general Armageddon who
gained notoriety for the rootless
campaign in area flattening civilian
areas while in charge of Russian forces
in support of the Assad regime now in
charge of turning the tide for Russian
troops who are facing crushing defeats
on the front line
this morning the Ukrainian defense
Ministry announced the recapture of five
more villages in Curson where we saw how
Russian troops have been overwhelmed by
Ukrainian tactics and Firepower
Ukrainian forces don't want us to reveal
their defensive position for obvious
security reasons but I can tell you
we've seen well-armed soldiers dug in
everywhere armored personnel carriers
tanks Heavy Artillery rocket launchers
it's not just about recapturing this
territory but holding it
Curson was the first major city to fall
to Russia in the initial Invasion a
retreat from the Strategic Port City in
the South would deliver the most
humiliating defeat of the war
not something Russia will give up
without a fight or further retaliation
this morning Russian intelligence
Services said eight people have been
arrested in connection with the blast on
the bridge accused of working with
Ukrainian agents Ukraine has not claimed
responsibility for the attack Tony
Charlie dagada for us once again in
Ukraine Charlie thank you very much